okay just for argument's sake suppose
we're nothing more than the sum total of
our genetic inheritance it's not as bad
as it sounds there are passages in our
DNA that are every bit as heroic as
anything ever written in any epic saga
[Music]
the mother is spotting deliberately
putting her own life in danger to alert
the herd and buy time for them
[Music]
so that her offspring and the rest of
the herd can get away if this isn't
heroism what is and yet this act of
valor is encoded in the Thompson
gazelles programming does that make it
any less brave she risks being eaten in
order to save her kin and that's the key
kin selection is that genetic impulse
for self-sacrifice prevalent throughout
the kingdoms of life even us skeptical
they do this thought experiment with me
imagine trying to sleep soundly at night
knowing that your children are starving
homeless are gravely ill for almost all
of us this would be unthinkable but
16,000 children die each day of easily
preventable hunger neglect or disease
children continued to die as we sleep
well and watch this show they're far
away they're not directly related to us
now tell me you don't believe in the
reality of kin selection we will die to
protect the carriers of our DNA and turn
away from the suffering of those who
don't kin selection can inspire us to
die saving a brother but it's also the
drive exploited by the demagogue and the
supremacists the us against them
another thought experiment imagine you
are making the first approach to a newly
discovered planet you've used various
techniques to ascertain that this world
supports an astonishing variety of life
forms you want to make contact but not
with their version of a scorpion Cobra
our great white shark you want to find
the life form that's most likely to
respond gently empathy and intelligence
these macaque monkeys are members of
what might be the most compassionate
species on earth this was demonstrated
in a ghastly series of experiments
conducted in the 1960s 15 macaques
were fed only if they were willing to
pull a chain an electrically shocked and
unrelated macaque whose agony was in
plain view through a one-way mirror if
they refused to shock another macaque
they starved after learning the ropes
the monkeys frequently refused to pull
the chain in one experiment only a small
percentage would do so while more than
two-thirds preferred to go hungry one
macaque went without food for nearly two
weeks
rather than heard its fellows here's the
part that really gets me macaques who
had themselves been shocked in previous
experiments were even less willing to
pull the chain relative social status or
gender of the macaques had little
bearing on their reluctance to hurt
others these experiments permit us to
glimpse and nonhumans
a saintly willingness to make sacrifices
in order to save others even those who
are not close kin
[Music]